yes of course we are worried about being
out and queer and outspoken and
political but one thing i will say about
what happened in Orlando for me anyways
is that I I think that one thing that
we've hesitated to celebrate some of the
most recent amazing things that have
happened like same-sex marriage in
Canada now and in the United States
those things are amazing but it it
stretches you know much broader than
that these things are very institutional
the ideas around homosexuality as a as a
society are still really challenging for
a lot of people and all all we want to
do as artists is support people you know
it's it's about looking out into the
audience and supporting people who are
queer and who are queer identified and
when something like this happens all we
think about is how can we keep doing
things that are good how can we keep
bringing the attention to things for
this community so as sad as I am about
what happened in Orlando and I mean we
were devastated by what happened in
Orlando but now we are we are united
again to like change things like gun
legislation toxic masculinity it this
idea that you know can you imagine this
this this man hates these people so much
that he would shoot them and kill them
like I mean this is like we have to talk
about these things of society we have to
it's the time in our community LGBT
people need to band together but so do
our allies and we need to stand up this
is the time to make change some was
saying earlier today that Washington
Post had an article about how if anyone
can change the way the NRA thinks it's
it's the LGBT community I think that but
we need to stay positive I mean we need
to mourn and we need to feel sad and we
need to be angry but we also need to
band together and remember and celebrate
how incredible and diverse our community
is and I think there's more love in this
world than hate and I think that it
would be sad to get hung up on the
hatred I think we need to focus on the
love and I think there's some pretty
incredible stuff happening in the LGBT
community and I think we've come a long
way